on uh hiring a new person until July 1
that gives uh myself and Council mcf uh
and also an um because she's lovely and
helping us out um to pull together the
youth Council and have conversations
with them about how the last year went
and what their suggestions may be um
that means we can collectively work on
the Constitution and bring it back to
council as well as uh solidify what that
budget line really looks like uh and
then look to advertise from the 1st of
July when it is an ltp um that saves
from having unbudgeted expenditure that
saves from um having to change a role on
the 1st of July um but also engages that
that youth Council and I'm hoping
that'll keep them engaged enough to
reapply on the on the 1st of July
whenever applications go out again c g
given that there is a six week delay
between likely advertising and someone
actually starting why can't we have a
report back at our next meeting and
finalize it so advertising can be done
six weeks before the 1st of July so
someone's actually up and running on the
1 of
July and by that stage we would have
made commitments on the long-term
plan don't particularly see an issue
with that but I will look to sta for
guidance on that one it means a little
bit of un budget expenditure but I do
recognize we have that 5,000 sitting
there
so different budget line but it's all
money I guess uh
Steve uh no real issue uh you worship I
think um the only potential minor
downside is only that uh you will have
an amount um slotted into your draft uh
ltp but it won't be confirmed until
probably the end of June um so you're
going to hire somewh on the basis that
the draft plan will find sufficient
support to be approved that's all um
that's a punt you can take um so it's
other than that uh we'll be guided by
your wishes and we'll execute
accordingly thank you for that Steve no
pressure are we all happy with that so
the idea is to recruit with a start date
of July 1st an ideal start date of July
1st with a report coming back to Council
in the next couple of Council meetings
from the newly elected members uh
councilor
Fraser uh you said recruiting yes is
that a0 two or
a025 is it 10s or is it 8s um I think
the idea is that that'll be figured out
before we advertise so it gives uh us
three some time to figure out what those
hours look like before we go out and
advertise for that role um six weeks
before the 1 of July which will
be around my birthday there somewhere
mid May
yeah which also means I'll be too old
for youth Council by then
yay do we want to move a recommendation
to that
effect oh we hav't also apologies
councelor Dex I know you're going to
jump in there uh we also haven't talked
about the the next recommendation which
is uh Council advising which committees
it considers suitable for a youth
Council to be appointed
to to you Council it is going to be
dependent on the skill set that we have
of Youth councilors and what they see is
the issues at the time I'm quite happy
to leave it open at this stage and for
them to actually guide us as to where
they think they are most useful I think
um it's a little bit um uh I won't say
arrogant but um uh for us to take tell
them that this is where you shall fit
isn't necessarily the type of
Cooperative approach I think we want to
um put forward um so I actually see it
as something as part of your talkies
with the youth Council and Reporting
back at the next meeting as to where
they see themselves
fitting and um just to um go back to a
point that was made earlier about do
they have a right to vote we have a
number of appointees to committees and
at a committee stage they have a right
to vote so i' actually like to leave it
open for the committee stage in terms of
what their status is or whether they're
reporting and um yeah I just want to
think that through a little bit
more Council councel M through the
worship yeah I I agree with you
completely Keith I think this is a
perfect chance of getting the youth to
say say to them what they want from the
job and we can work with them that way
and I think it's cor so I agree
completely
do any of uh sorry I'm putting my chairs
on the spot here but do any of the
chairs have an issue with youth Council
potentially being able to vote on their
committees if they are
appointed the only concern I would maybe
raise is around audit and risk just
because it is that higher level
stuff but I don't see an issue maybe yes
it's an infrastructure but if we get I
don't want to restrict someone who's
really into pipes on the ground and all
the other fun stuff that we deal with or
policy and Regulatory either Council
Deon thank you worship um as chair of
the community wellbeing I would welcome
a youth counselor on that
committee with voting
rights with voting rights
yes thank you councelor councelor
Phillips yeah worship I would disagree
with this because at the end of the day
we have a community Bo Mata who is jul
elected by elected member by members of
the community those members five members
do not have voting rights in Council
they may only make recommendations and
they rely on the councilors around the
table to make their decision for
them un understood councilor Phillips
would only be the subcommittee so the
counsel it be work the same as the
community board so it would still come
to full Council so full Council they
wouldn't have voting rights so the rest
of the council could say no against what
the youth Council had voted on if that
makes sense yeah I understand that I
understand that but what I'm saying here
is that you don't even you don't invite
the Mata community board to the reg Tre
in
um uh Community wellbeing meeting so you
know I'm just a little bit
gunshy31 we're saying yes we want you
but we don't really care you know we've
got to send the message out to the say
they're important and I think that's a
message that we can do it's a it's a
committee level is different I think
that's it's a message we got to get
straight down the line we can't say to
them that you can be in one committee
and not the other if someone's keen on
one committee I say more PA to them come
to it and do something and add to
it councelor gard and then myself I
think they still have speaking rights
and that's quite adequate but to give
them voting rights is probably you'd
have to go back to the right
pars thank you counselor I'm going to
put this conversation on ice because I
think it should be something that's
discussed as part of the Constitution
when we get it finalized are we happy
just at least for membership at this
point in time we can Circle back to the
the voting rights when we've got
everything a bit
clearer all of the chairs are
comfortable with that
yep uh
are we can we get a recommendation from
the floor for those two bottom
recommendations I can suggest one if if
that's
easier I will suggest okay so um could I
have a mve that uh the council
advise um that it considers all all
committees uh suable for a youth
counselor to be appointed
to uh and that the council confirm
option one with the amendment that the
recruitment process will start six weeks
before the 1st of
July is that clear in everyone's
mind can I get a mover for those
counselor
mcf I would like to second that that's
okay second from the
chair any further discussion councelor
dexon and then councelor Reed
thank you wish I'd just like to ask then
um you need an option there about the
long-term plan for funding forthcoming
long-term
plan funding would be adopted through
the forthcoming long-term plan if you're
going to
recruit starting on the 1 of
July correct me if I'm wrong but all
long-term plan budgeting is all Up For
Debate so at work would have to still be
confirmed as part of the long-term plan
so there there is a potential that we
can't fund the role because it's not put
in the long-term plan we we can't force
it on there now because we have to
consult on that document that make
sense so that that that six weeks if we
get them before the 1 of July will be
unbudgeted expenditure and then
everything else after that will have to
be the long-term
plan that make
sense that Mak
sense
La is going to tell me how it's meant to
be uh through your worship um the eled
members will still have opportunity to
debate this as part of the long-term
plan process and by the time we get to
may we should be very well along that
process so you'll know what you're
recommending and not recommending so
we've still got a window of opportunity
there um to for this to be
considered thank you la I summed up a
whole lot better than I did uh councelor
Reed yeah it's it's not a comment about
anything it's just a comment about the
fact that the report came in there's
been an excellent discussion I apologize
if the staff has had time moved but it's
actually really good to see everybody
around the table debating this and not
just rolling over and expecting things
to happen when they can't happen and um
I just look forward to going forward
that the youth Council will be
revitalized and I'm sure they'll add a
lot once again to the gore District
Council thank thank you
counselors thank you counselor I
absolutely concur um I think being a a
young elected member um it's it's very
it's it's I'm not allowed to use the
word cool up here as much as I do but
it's very cool um to see such a robust
debate and yes that longevity of the
youth Council and that re
viralization on that positive note uh
unless there's any further discussion I
will put the motion all those in favor
please say I
and against the motion is carried thank
you
councilors item number 10 James cuming
community center and library final
project cost would the chief executive
like to speak to this
item uh just briefly your worship um
conscious of time but I thought it was
um important to put up the final cost of
this project uh before you it was a
significant Capital project uh as I said
in my report conceived during lockdown
uh I think there's some solitary lessons
here for future councils someone who's
uh going to depart the role shortly uh
it's very easy for a council to be
almost bullied into backing off uh when
projects come up and you get a cacophony
of opposition on the basis of often of
cost but not value and of often uh
people can't see what the finished
product might be I think this particular
project uh it dawned on me that it was
controversial at the time but as the
project unfolded and people could see
what was was possible I felt myself that
the uh the opposition to the project uh
almost diluted commensurate with the
advancement of the project and I just
think that's it's important that for a
council to always think about the
long-term value uh and not just uh freak
out about the cost in this particular
case of course the cost was
significantly defrayed by contributions
from central government and the MVM
Financial contribution uh so it's
satisfying that final cost is just a
little tick over project budget uh and
we Advanced it in a very high
inflationary environment uh where
construction costs were literally going
through the roof uh and I want want to
just
uh acknowledge the the good work of
Signal Management Group which uh made
Advanced orders materials very early in
the pce to to lock in uh prices uh and
to protect us from what were some pretty
Savage increases that uh occurred in the
industry during the course of this
particular project and I do Wonder like
with now with the community the project
has been finished uh you know we if we
hadn't have gone withe of that project
the council would have still been
grappling with a James cuming Wing that
had um become very tired and looked
particularly awful uh with ju toos with
the upgraded Civic Administration build
next door so it's really nice to see
what I refer to now as a Civic Precinct
that has been developed and should serve
this community for decades to come thank
you thank you Steve
councelors councelor Reed thank you Mr
Mayor yes I think it's um it's a great
asset to our community and the fact that
50% of more than 50% was funded by
outside sources is um reflects on the
work that the chief executive and the
librarian did at the time um very much
under pressure and we've certainly got a
good um a really wonderful resource and
the cost of refurbishing the JC Wing I
do remember being at a meeting where
that was actually brought to the table
and it was well over a million dollars
closer to two so even if you know you
take that off the other 50% we've done
very well out of this project and once
again I'll repeat my late husband's
Mantra do it once do it right and we
have and congratulations to the chief
executive thank you councelor councelor
mcf yes uh just through your worship
obviously compliments to the staff and
the CEO um I think we should actually be
sharing it from the rooftop
1% you know you look around the country
at the moment at the blowouts central
government pulling funding millions and
millions of dollars has gone down the
gutter the council had foresight with
some great
advice um and and some you know hard
decisions to make with a lot of
criticism uh around refurbishing um both
the community center like James cuming
wing and the library um we've stuck by
the uh fact that that the James coming
Wing is still Honors that that respect
to that that era and the community
groups that are using it I've heard
nothing but price um you know 1% full
credit I think uh the council compet
itself on the back to have bought that
in um under such a tight and um you know
very very um hard Market particularly
when we had construction costs that we
we did have um fears around cost
blowouts but it was well and truly
managed and held um in hand so no good
job done and the recommendation um I
definitely support
that thank you councelor councelor
Gardine it's 232 of
1% they
right thank you councelor g gine
councilor uh Paul
mcf thank you wish i' like to look
freely admit here um I was did against
the library when it was first murdered
and I was wrong you've done a great job
staff Steve take my hat off here the
town in 10 years time are going to look
back and think well we've got fantastic
facilities so I'm sorry I was wrong fre
admit it but you've done a great job so
well done everybody
[Music]
here thank you councelor Council Dixon
thank you worship I'd just like to
concur with everyone's comments but say
that there has been a lot of people I
know they were very against the library
and now they've used the library they've
come and they've used the facilities and
they're very pleased and happy to have
it in the town so congratulations to you
Steve and the staff and everyone who put
this together I think it's great that
we've come in with such a small increase
on the
budget thank you councelor councelor
McKenzie I totally admit to be being one
of the nay sers in the early days myself
I put my hand up and I say that just two
small points um additional work there
was one there for five something for a
temporary server room why do we need
that and the Transformer upgrade I
thought they would have probably been
included in the initial price but apart
from that I've got nothing to add to
what folks have said I I thought that
those two things the temporary server
room why was that needed and the
Transformer upgrade that whoever was in
charge of electrical engineering
probably should have sused that out
before it had to come um in as
additional work but that's all I have to
comment on thank
you Steve did you have did anyone have
any insight on that
one
La three year worship the temporary
server room was required because the
server room was situated in the previous
old part of the building so was it's
actually situated in the James cuming um
Community Center um and it Serv the
whole building if we had not moved that
we would not have been able to operate
so we had to put in place a temporary
one to continue the um operations of
council um during that process um once
and the new server room was been was
part of the new build in the library so
that's just clarifying clarifying that
one with the Transformer upgrade uh
there was a loading um as with with the
um this building here coming online the
Civic building um we identified some
that the new library would add
additional loading to current
Transformer so a new Transformer had to
be transform had to be upgraded to
accommodate the the additional loading
of both
buildings thank you L set satisfy you
there Council
McKenzie cool thank you
counselor any further
comments I think there's been a lot of
congratula congratulating of of Staff
which is which is definitely warranted
but um I also just want to say uh a
congratulations to the counselors who
who are still sitting around this table
who made that cous decision um it's hard
making making big budget calls like that
um but but you did it and and it's
definitely benefiting the the community
so I also pet yourself on the back for
that one as
well councelor Reed thank I just we've
all been sitting here saying that it's
been under budget but just for uh rate
payers interest the actual sum is
$4,799 so that's. 32 of 1% over budget
it's minuscule so just so that everybody
in the community is well aware of that
number thank you councelor Reed uh do we
have a move councelor re are you happy
to move that report and a second
councelor Rich
mfil
uh on to figuring out what to do with
the the old library as we close the book
on this project uh but I will put the
motion all those in favor please say I
and against the motion is carried thank
you councilors item
11 the regional climate change working
group update uh before I throw this to
Jason uh as the community and hopefully
also councils are aware uh this has been
hot debate at both inago city council
and also South and District Council um
I know from Council hval that there are
some some updates which I'm sure will be
expressed today um can keep this
conversation light because I know there
are some massive changes uh and in light
of fogging a dead horse um those changes
I'm sure will come um but just wanted to
preface that um we are the last uh
Council on the rank to discuss this um
and a lot of the issues have been have
been threshed out but I will throw to um
Jason for an update
uh thank you worship just I guess a
couple of things to on on those those
points you raised so yes it has been in
front of inago city and South District
environment South will see it tomorrow
um a couple of the I guess the themes
have come through from those and I'll
I'll let Keith speak on them too just
really around this this this strategy
is and really about Council strategy so
it's not necessarily a strategy for the
whole region and how it will approach Ro
climate change it's really a discussion
for the local authorities and how they
talk together the whole point of the um
working group coming together and doing
something regionally was to utilize the
skill sets we have across we don't have
loads of that um uh in each Council but
pulling our resources to understand
climate change and how we can have those
discussions going forward um and really
I guess the other thing is that it's a
there's two key parts of the strategy
around one around medication
um which has received a fa bit of
commentary that really is around what
council can do with its own admission so
for us that first part of that challenge
which we've talked about previously is
around understanding our own emissions
from our the day-to-day work that we do
as a council and how much we're
contributing to uh climate change um the
second part though is is around
adaptation and that's very much a a
collective concern which really is
around again continuing those
conversations regionally about how we
can best um adapt to the challenges of
climate change we're all aware of the
increasing intensity of weather events
that we see um we have a pretty
significant body of water that throws
flows through our district and we need a
catchment approach to understand the
risks and how we can continue to
mitigate those over um over the coming
years and so that's really um the nuts
and bolts of the strategy but from from
a staff point of view it's time for me
to sit back and let you guys discuss
what you think are the key issues about
it and whether or not you're happy to
endorse this um climate change strategy
which again just to highlight will go
out through environment southland's uh
long-term plan process um which will
then reach all rate payers across the
region for comment and
feedback thank you thank you Jason just
before I throw it to council hoval did
ICC and STC endorse it
I I don't believe they did but I don't
know if you've seen it they did they did
endorse it I've seen sorry I've seen
sdc's they endorsed it subject to a
couple of additions and so there's a
there'll be a meeting of the working
group to make potentially some changes
to that before it goes out so it was
endorsed by inago city with two people
voting
against and um thank you Jason um you've
used up about um 50% of the notes that I
had and thank you for the nice um clear
description key issue is that the
document is focusing just on the
activities of the councils not on the
wider public um but I actually found a
few places in the document where that's
a little bit confused and um there is an
expectation that we would be doing
things moving forward um that actually
had relevance um to The Wider public and
um we had the first of the me meetings
um earlier this week um Monday no no uh
must been last week Friday um looking at
where too from here so the part one that
you've got the dra uh the copy of there
is really the strategy framework and
then we're moving forward um to a
strategy
implementation there is a report to go
to the um miral Forum on the 1st of
March setting out what the working party
that we have at present sees as the
appropriate way of moving forward and uh
once that report has been done and the
report back to this Council there will
be a need to look at what representation
we have moving forward um so let's just
deal with it um step by
step there is an expectation in the
document that the gore District Council
will in the next 12 months undertake a
view of its activities to identify its
carbon footprint and that is to provide
a baseline for measuring um going
forward um in Vago City and Southland
District have been through that exercise
and they're really dependent on on us to
follow that through and that will be a
discussion that we need to have as part
of the um District
plan um sorry as part of the long-term
plan the key part that's in the document
are the principles and aspirations and
if there's any feedback on those um then
then um there is a meeting being held
next week to look at the feedback of all
of the councils and happy to take any
comment that counselors um may have but
I believe that we have a
responsibility not only for the current
Generations but future generations to be
an active um participant in the process
going forward which will mean that time
of Staff counselors and a financial
commitment that we need to be giv um as
as we do move forward I'm happy to
respond to any questions that um people
may have with a bit of help from Jason
no doubt and to consider any
feedback thank you counselor uh
councilors questions comments
concerns councilor
Gardine some of the some of the concerns
I have is probably when you look at page
57 of the report um our biggest emitter
in the um sector is agriculture and um
some people would argue that we haven't
had any offsets and um sometimes that
argument is still out there how how is
methane measured against carbon and um
it's methane goes around in the circle
in my opinion and gr sheep eat grass
grass catches carbon and we have trees
and grass and we don't get any credits
for it
so I think the basic mathematics is
fluid and a lot of other Farmers would
think the same but also in our Council
we have a lot of reserves a lot of trees
a lot of grass no
credits and we have some of the best
parks and reserves in New Zealand and um
we are the
credits so to to reach those goals by
2050 you'd have to destock every Farm in
the gore District of sheep and cattle
and be growing trees only under the
present rules and there would be
disaster for our
region
um so I think there has to be more
debate on this and it will be in central
government and it is say the new
government will be flagged with this
issue there definitely will be work done
on how to mitigate methane and how to
but that's going to take time and in
breeding circles it doesn't happen in a
short time frame and and um it can take
generations of stock to be able to breed
through that to the genetics or else
it's going to be um some sort of
injection or feed supplement that you
feed the animals to cut down the methane
but looking at that blue figure on page
58 that's going to be the
huge um project for this district is how
toit lower your greenhouse gases in the
agriculture
sector thank you counselor and yeah
appreciate that that Bleak picture of uh
only trees and and Gore um councilor
Stringer and then councel
mcell thank you worship um having read
the um report there also the figures for
the stationary energy uh
um uh Mis represent what shown on the
graph there um there has been a
national um carbon allocation applied to
the power that the Ty Point smelter uses
even though it's all carbon neutral
through Hydro production they've applied
a um standard um Huntley um figure to
the PA that's used so that has um
inflated the graph there um also at the
end of the day I see that the forestry
is growing but also we can't eat pine
kinds as
well thank you councelor councelor n now
yeah I would agree with the comments of
both councelor string and councelor G we
just can't exist here with without um
agriculture in this District that's what
this T Town's based on and we we we need
that agricultural production and the
world needs food so we just have to keep
doing it you know it says here that we
produce n 2% of the population and
contribute
9.7% of the emissions but you know this
way it's going to have to have to be we
just have to grow the grow the food if
you think of you're going to change to
cropping or something else well that
consumes a hell of a lot of
uh carbon to do that as well and your
soils just can't sustain continual
cropping that they just fall apart the
so we we need to stick with sheep and
beef in some
form thank you councelor councelor
mcf through your worship look I just I a
red flag when I when I saw the United
Nations body for assessing the science
related to climate change I've got no
time for them uh because I think they
they the way they measure things is is
not right and I think what John said and
and the other people around um so I
think we've got to be very careful what
we decide got to look and do it very
carefully for us here in our district
not just everywhere
else councelor Dixon then councel FR
thank you worship um I understand that
central government have not included
farming in the climate change um
policies that they have so far so I
don't see that we should be either but I
I also feel that um this is about our
Council would I be correct Council HOV
and not the whole farming District this
is just about us and I think it's very
important that we our council is
included so we actually have a say about
these
things thank you councelor councel
Fraser I thank you your worship I I
don't disagree with councelor Dixon but
when I see papers like this coming out I
I start to worry and when I was around
in Carlos St when we were going to run
out of fuel in the 70s and it just
turned out to be another
tax um and I look at climate change and
I look at cop 28 whatever it was where
880,000 people flew in to the UAE to
talk about climate change but that's not
counted and when you look at New
Zealand's contributions to clim to to
that we're
17% although we can make a small
difference until you talk to China India
America and all these other countries
our little difference won't make a
difference so yes I understand why it's
here and I I struggle sometimes with
some of the data that's been collected
and I totally agree with councilor Paul
mcf about the UN um it's just I I I just
think that we look at stuff like this
and in the end what is it going to cost
our Rays if we start carrying down these
lines all the way when we've talked
about budget wise we're struggling so I
I think we just got to be very
careful thank you
counselor do we have any comments on the
document in front of us and our
council's
contribution councilor Rich
mcf yes thank you worship um it's
interesting we've discussed that uh
fossil fuels letter and now we have this
as an item about seven later so um
there's obviously an inherent link
between various things in in the world I
think probably when you look at the
document uh you have to be seen to be
done and agricultural production as
councilor Gardon said it's it's the
backbone of the country um our dairy
industry has is one of the highest rated
in the world for the lowest carbon
footprint for per liter production um we
punch above our weight we're very very
small but I think when you look at uh
what's contained in here we need to have
a s Source document that needs to be
worked through um because we have to be
seen to be actually doing that it's a
bit like the the letter before we have
to have one each way um if we don't have
it someone will mandate it or someone
will come along and tell us or the UN
will turn up um so I think the document
itself has got some great working
application in there but there is
matters that I think probably councilor
hovell referred to um around actual
structure within Council and outside
groups that are their involvement um to
stick our head in the sand we can't do
it we need to be um we need to be
working together um the Mata river flows
through how many different Council
groups along with arti it doesn't stop
and suddenly say I'm going into southern
district now it goes through Gore
District it goes through South district
and then eventually I think it ends up
an environment South when it goes into
the straight so we need to hold hands to
work together um we need to have Source
documents around there so I'm happy that
there's something on paper but um
there's some more work to to be done
around
it thank you counselor and then on that
point around der I know that myself and
Steve had some very exciting
conversations with fontier about their
change um from from coal to uh electric
boilers which will massively reduce um
the the CO2 emissions uh within our
region um as as well as our district uh
with wanting to phase out coal by 2037
so there is progress there um it's also
doing our bit as a council to to help
out and fully acknowledge councelor
Fraser um that we a very small portion
um but if we can do a little bit without
impacting our rate payers then I I think
we should do we have any comments on the
document itself any amendments changes
are we following the lead of uh sister
councils on the changes they' like to
make
councilor
Gardine just I noticed on the flood
Banking and the photo there you know the
mitigation of um problems of flooding is
it's very important for our town of Gore
and um I think the flood Banks but it
also goes hand inand with another
problem is the gravel buildup in the
rivers and I think that still has to be
addressed and I think we have a weak
Council and a Regional Council hasn't
faced up to that and the Regional
Council needs to face up to allowing
consent for gravel extraction and the uh
on the top side of bridges and the towns
to um mitigate
flooding so I think without jumping the
gun I think Council has a bit of an
update there with the climate change
committee starting to turn their focus
towards gravel extraction is that that
correct or have I put my foot in at
there um I was going to wait for the
mural Forum to sign off um on on the
direction that it's going but uh I guess
it it just reinforces is um the comment
from councelor Gardine where the the um
group that are currently working
together from the councils see graval
removal is a key issue that needs to be
addressed and we'll take a proposal to
um the mural Forum on in that
regard thank you councelor councelor
mcf we just through your worship to
councelor H um you're obviously working
closely within this and obviously this
could be addressed to Jason uh as well
that the source document here do you
think it'll give us any more strength
amongst the other councils when we go to
them to to ask these questions or try
and get our aspirations met as they put
in there do you think this is going to
help
us uh it's been a long process to get
agreement on the aspirations and and the
direction and with a considerable amount
of time actually been spent on one or
two words rather than the overall
Concepts and I think the point that we
got to is is one that I agree with and
thankful for that we have been able to
reach an overall um agreement for going
forward but all we've done is created
the framework 12 months um we need to be
moving forward a lot quicker at the
implementation level of what we as a
council can and all the councils
together and individually can be doing
in response to um what what is now
accepted um changes that that are
happening to our environment and that's
going to require us to think about um
the way that we interact with um uh not
only um droughts and and um um flooding
um and and if we're going to have
progress towards droughts then at some
point we will need to engage with our
community over the way that we manage
our water supply in our urban areas um
in terms of some of the wider impacts
that are happening changes in climate
change impacts on people's Health as
well and the warm homes trust has got an
important role to play in terms of um
providing healthy homes so um it's the
framework for moving forward and I've
highlighted a couple of issues in the
gravel um
where um I just say that um Great South
and its days ADV Venture Southland has
done a lot of work in terms of The Wider
things that industry can do um so I see
the framework moving forward is that the
group we've got will be focusing on the
councils and uh Great South will be
continuing I hope with further work that
actually highlights what the wider
communities can be doing and integrating
the
two on that basis I'd like to move the
recommendation thank you councelor I was
just about to say that uh seconded by
councilor Richard mcf any further
discussion I will put the motion all
those in favor please say I and against
the motion is carried thank you
counselors uh summary of The meral Forum
um and I know this meeting's running on
a bit but uh if is there any questions
around this mural Forum I might touch a
little bit on uh me and Council Phillips
Adventure today um because I think
there's some important stuff in there
too do we have any questions on this
mural Forum in front of us
no so just as a bit of an update um
today uh myself and Council Phillips
were down at muku M um and we met uh
with the uh four four
the congregation of the for runanga and
there was also um the new head of natu
there as well um so it was great that he
made time to be with us uh and then
following that we had the joint um
Southland anago meril Forum um with both
Minister uh Penny Simmons and uh
Minister Mark Patterson there uh so that
was some great robust discussion uh some
key takeaways that I just wanted to uh
forward on to uh counselors um and the
public as well um seeing as um we were
on morning report this morning for our
three Waters conversation the and the
problems that we've got ahead of us uh
we have uh this might be a surprise to
to Steve but we've lifted over the chief
Executives to um come up with a solution
for three Waters uh and come back to the
respective mural forums moving forward
so thank you in advance Steve
um uh looking at different options
around what does a CCO look like um what
does different things look like uh the
indication that we're getting from
Wellington at this stage is they're
looking at us at Solutions um and we're
kind of getting as a at a point um at
local government of if we don't think of
solutions ourselves um we're looking at
expensive rate hikes um and and our rate
payers just can't afford that so um we
need to uh get our get our staff to come
up with a bit of a solution for us and
then have that debate around the table
so that's sitting with the two
Executives and hopefully we'll get a
report back at the next meal for which
as Council haval said was in
March uh other topics that were
discussed of
relevance can you think of any councilor
Phillips um there was there was a whole
whole bunch there there was a
recommendation that went through um we
didn't weren't able to stick around um
to see the finalization of it but uh
basically something along the lines of
uh the Ms and chaires uh supporting the
the treaty as at stands so um showing
our partners at at naho that um we are
we're looking forward to still work
alongside them um despite all of the
noise that's going on at the moment um
but that's that's me and shears that's
that's not binding the council to that
we we couldn't do that in good faith
without coming and talking to our
councils uh councelor Phillips there was
just one thing that was interesting to
me that night who were um wishing to put
more responsibility on their local um
run
hangers which I found very
interesting um you know make
recommendations on things yeah so
similar to the conversation that I guess
we're having with central government the
the center of natoo and and Christ
Church want to divest a lot of their
powers into the region so they actually
want regions to make a lot more of
decision making rather than the
PowerHouse and and Cho making all of it
so um hopefully this is the aspirations
of of the new leader um wanting to give
a bit more more power and responsibility
to the different run around um around
the the south island so um we'll see how
that looks that was one of his his
bigger aspirations um and we'll see how
that looks for us but um that
partnership is still alive and healthy
um and yeah just continuing to look look
forward to working
together I think that's about it um but
I'm sure we'll we'll have further
discussion but those are those are some
key updates that I'd just like to to add
um while we're here back to this m Forum
um could I have a move that these
minutes are
received uh Council M Now seconded by
councilor Reed I put the motion all
those in favor please say I and against
the motion is carried waset meetings do
Council want to speak to this at all I'm
happy to respond to any questions people
may have it's fairly clear what's there
I think they're a while back because I
was still on the committee at that stage
yet they're playing a bit of
catchup no questions could I be a move
that those minutes have received Council
Gardone second by Council Dixon all
those in favor please say
I and against the motion is carried
minutes of the mat community board
meeting uh councilor Phillips did you
want to speak to these at all I think
we've got stuff in committee as well so
um just remind I could try and re uh
answer questions but I was not present
at the
meeting ah yes you were with
us uh do we have any questions
for uh I'm going to say Susan was
probably the only one there
or just anything that we'd like to
discuss in those
minutes I don't think there is anything
in here
that specifically
needs uh council's
attention the cultural issues around the
pit symmetry the is there anything there
cultur there was a query around uh I see
Colleen T asked about the cultural
considerations of having pet per and I'm
told it's a work in progress it is it
okay
yeah Council Phillips yeah thank you
wish I just about to say that that most
of the um things within the meeting were
uh to come back to board to the
board I just like to make comment about
the signs if it was possible and I did
make a um
a comment to the board even though I
wasn't present at the meeting about the
highway signs and I just said to the to
them to be in to be patient uh that that
is including the the uh a residents of
Mata and then the people that come past
please be patient at the moment um
they're they're not fully completed um
but you're more than willing to uh stop
in a safe place and go back and have a
look at them visually I think they're
they are they're really
impressive and uh the
Chrisman uh who um designed the the sign
was right on the brief that uh we said
to them right at the start and uh they
may be just slightly darker than shade
than that we thought they were going to
be and that was due to the aspect of
making the graffiti
um making them anti- graffiti which
would have left them if we didn't darken
it up left them with the strings in the
concrete and that's what we didn't want
so uh just be be patient let's get the
other one in the north side let's get it
up and if we need to make a bit of
change that we can later in later on
just with a letter lettering lighten it
up but apart from that very
impressed thank you counselor uh yes
this was a learning curve for me uh I
think this has already been said to
counselors but the metal is quau on
metal is that correct so it is meant to
go a bright orange once it's finished
ctin yeah uh so it should be a bright
orange in the next 6 to 12 months so
watch for space um and if not we might
end up painting it so we'll see how we
get on uh could I pleas move those
minutes are
received councelor Fraser SE
goodby councelor Richard mcf I will put
the motion all those in favor please say
I and against the motion is carried
community Services bulletin any queries
in here Council
h i um ask for this to be included in
the council agenda because I think
there's some nice um gritty bits in
there that should be noted in
particularly the Maru wide um Center has
achieved funding of 120,000 that they've
raised to help with the fit out uh the
library stats are showing an incredible
amount of increase in use compared to
last month um and and which is great and
also the revenue at The Visitor Center
is up significantly compared to last
year and I think they're all points that
that are good news and we should be
noting
them thank you councilor point of
clarification that 120k is that that's
to the hooken Moonshine Museum redevelop
and not the m center funding that they
need it's not part of that
400k I could be wrong but that's just
how I read it
is that a that separate funding to
finish off the Moonshine
Museum no no that's okay a big chunk of
money that raised so it's not coming
from the right yeah yeah thank thank you
for that counselor uh councelor
Reed me um M Council heral stole a
little bit of my thunder but hey once
again surprisingly enough it's the
library um particularly across those
increases it's just amazing um but also
I'd like to make mention of the fact
that the Emma and the staff operated
through the Christmas and New Year Break
um and every time I went in it was choca
block people using computers all sorts
of things and I guess we all forget at
our Peril as Emma reminded me that
people some people rely on the library
facilities to actually go in there and
pay their bills online things like that
do their banking um so you know really
it's it's a one siiz fits all and the
other thing I'd like to say too is the
um the staff have those really great
innovative ideas that are actually out
there promoting it in the district for
the young people the kids um all of the
different functions that they're doing
it's it's a it's a real credit to them
and I'm really proud of the way that
they step up and you go into the library
they're always happy there's always a
smiling face long may that
continue thank you
counselor any further
comment look oh sorry councelor Phillips
thank you worship uh it just goes to
highlight how how hard the staff work
for us and and they have to be
congratulated and we just like to invite
every counselor down on the 2nd of March
to Mata
to our uh play in the play playground
scenario in Mata and that at Mata so
you're more than welcome you probably
had an invitation on your iPad so please
come
down thank you counselor I think we'll
see a lot of councilors out and about um
the public watching and and in the
gallery um we've got quite a few events
coming up that I know that counselors
are involved in um I think we'll all be
at Field Days by one or two of us so so
come and have a chat um we'll be at on
the Fly we'll be at um the Moonshine uh
Trail walk and ride we'll be at I'll be
at the matot rodeo so there's plenty of
places to um have a yarn um and then
we'll be out in about even more with the
ltp uh councelor Reed thanks again sorry
make it short it was really good to get
the community services bulletin earlier
and then to see it published on the
agenda like this I'd like thank you
Council and I'd like to see that
continue
AB yeah thank you counselor um might
have a discussion with that offline I'm
just wey of the amount of minutes and
things that we're now accepting at the
back end of our agendas but that's a
that's a discussion that we can have
have seen celebrate once upon a time it
was always on the
agenda thank you counselor yeah
uh could I please have a move that this
is I believe it's received yes received
uh councilor read see and bu Council me
to now I will put the motion all those
in favor please say I and against the
motion is carried council is okay with
us boxing on we've only got a short but
and are we all okay with it because we
just had a few interruptions that have
given us breaks in between i' let's
continue on it's cool um I'd like to
move from the cheer the public be
excluded from the following parts the
proceeding of this meeting name of the
items listed below which is the proposed
sale of